us
l
check check check all
right w
to good afternoon everyone turn the game
audio down a little bit my name is Nick
sitting here with uh M Mr Michael Mah
Hardy what's up dude what are we playing
today play Mafia 3 the first hour of the
campaign or so um so I'm going to start
on I'll go
medium turn a assist low let's get right
into it yeah let's probably a cut scene
at the beginning we can shut up during
that so this game comes out when uh in
the US tomorrow tomorrow you might have
you might be able to pre-load it tonight
or something I think think so I just
started pread Australia and what not
later yeah shout out if you're in
Australia you can play now uh we are
playing on Xbox one yeah this is Xbox
One cool it's on PS4 and PC as
well sick so this is new borell they're
showing essentially fictionalized
version of New Orleans we did an entire
uh documentary episode about how they
kind of made it if you want to watch
that it's called Reviving Mafia Reviving
mafia series go check it on YouTube or
our site if you guys have any questions
for the Mafia 3 expert himself Mike um
just toss him up in the uh the comments
I will team him up for him I have not
played the game yet so I'm basically
going to be asking you a ton of quick
questions sweet got a little note here
about the authenticity of the time
period I
guess
new
Boro a modern city with traditional
Southern
values I underestimated how far he was
going to
go what he was willing to do visit the
historic French Ward and enjoy local
cuisine at one of our festar restaurants
killing them wasn't enough link and Clay
was using them to send a message or
spend the afternoon in the bou and and
take in its natural
splend Maro had no idea what he was
going to
unleash new Boro safe family oriented
Farm make it your next vacation
destination this city survived the War
of 1812 the Civil War and God knows how
many hurricanes how much when Lincoln
clay went after the mob he inflicted
more damage than all the wars and
hurricanes
combined Lan's mother abandoned him in
oh
1947 couple of years after he was born
his mother I heard she was
Dominican I always figured his father
was white maybe even not Italian not
that it
mattered back then if you look black
you
black same as today I
suppose he stayed at the offing edge
until
1958 now when did you meet Lincoln click
1966 I was running Black Ops out of LA
on behalf of the
CIA he was loaned out to me via joint
CIA DOD task force a quiet
boy good boy
two purple hearts the bronze star and
the distinguished service cross he
served this country with honor and
distinction after the city Clos the
orphanage you fell in with Sammy
Robinson Sammy ran the black mob over
and Del re holla I can't say I
approved but often Colored Boys didn't
have a lot of options back
then boys like Lincoln ones who been a
abandon they're always looking for a
home always looking for a place to
belong I think he thought he'd finding
an
army thing
is once that's
lost you can never get it back
again when he returned from the
war lincol ended back up over at
Samy now Samy owed the Italian mob a
whole lot of
money and he needed Lincoln's
help it's a damn shame what
happened it breaks my
heart all
right sweet
still say this is the craziest goddamn
thing I ever heard using real money to
rob the feds well hell man not like this
is our cash this all came from
scaleta besides peanuts compared to what
we going to haul out of there is
everything we need to burn yeah that's
it I grab the keys to the truck then we
can get the [__] out of here yeah
all right here we go Lincoln pick up the
keys this is Lincoln clay with the
biggest triceps I've ever seen in my
life so is lincol
CL um is he the main character like
this
we make
it can I pick what's going on
here oh here we go there wondering if I
can I don't think I need him but I'll
bring him what are you going to use him
for I we should get going fig you got
the keys so you can drive do a lot with
the body come on let's get the hell out
of here actually down for a
second well
then all right let's go out of
here all right got the
keys doesn't sound
good here we
go
yeah I want to know how to control the
radio is it the speedo on the bottom
easy head we don't need cops crawling up
our
asses myp [__] back there he ain't got
no idea what he's in for what was this
cut 5% they're about not like he'll be
able to spend it fed be watching every
the from the beginning of the we just
decent amount it's a big game though
always a good idea to dangle someone out
there use them to get everybody's
attention and you just slip away [__]
roads so answer me this what's the
craziest thing you saw there you don't
want to know hell man I'm a tax I got
the right to know how my money's being
spent oh Georgie Maro pays taxes damn
right I do that's how they got out
Italian goingon for no [__] tax got
same last name of s going answer the
question yeah get out of
here we on the coast to Quang n
evacuating the civies for Charlie
overran everything anyway we getting him
onto a medical ship and this woman walks
if you have any questions for M she got
a baby in one hand leash to a pig in the
other she starts up the ramp and MP
stops her and tells her you can only
bring one thing on board so she tosses
the baby into the water MP goes ape
tells someone dive in after the kid
starts screaming at the woman wants to
know what the [__] she's thinking you
know what she says to him she says I can
always have another baby
Jesus [__] Christ hey man you
asked yeah but I thought you going to
tell me a story about some go getting
his dick blown off or something I mean
God damn it's not a fault but not like
you think conditions over there man
Jesus Christ new boell one day you're
raising cend
your next day everything flat you put
people up against the wall new orans
they will do anything is about that
better been one delicious [__] pig
all right like we're going through the
French W coming up on it have you been
to New Orleans I have not oh pretty fun
been once who
it it was what for the game was this to
go visit for the game no I didn't go on
that trip people did
though sorry F you
doing
sorry it's going too smooth that Reserve
probably won't be too keen on you waling
around with that piece of yours I'll
just leave is this a geographically
architectural architecturally it looks
like it no geographically they added uh
a lot of Hills to make it more fun to
drive around New Orleans pretty Flat
City it's like right on sea
level
back it up to the loading
dock some of these fellas might get a
little uh rough with the language and
Ain like I never been called [__]
before I know but I'm just saying if I
go along with it ain't nothing
poison the only thing I care about it's
getting our hands on that
money
all right see how this shs out we I say
something about being hot that's when we
make our move all right door we looking
for shot here we
go puts up the glass rep of the boying
crew wa I didn't how does he know who I
am [__] this [__] heel doing
here affirmative action you know how it
is old country is spinning around a
goddamn
toilet all right I'm going to go in
hopefully you're fine with that so what
is the specific time of um history this
take place
1968 year follow me T Martin Luther King
was assassinated Bobby Kennedy was
assassinated trck the black power salute
the Mexico City Olympics how much yall
bring in um 238 offensive in Vietnam a
lot [__] happened in 1968 bills mostly
I'll have Miss office when we're done
she'll conf find the delivery appreciate
it there we
go boy pull your head out and grab that
money my
bad all of it yeah look at those muscles
I think you can handle it he's pretty
Jack and again we're playing on Xbox
One there's
one all right money would be heavy that
much money wait strong guy or something
was it strong guys or
something all
right it's pretty lack security for the
federal Reser check that scatter gun you
packing anything still in training good
one less goddamn thing for me to worry
about you can pick it up on the way
out
buying rooms down in the cellar this
way I ain't seen yall around these part
before over in Georgia he just got out
the service my trying to get on here for
over a year now was in the Navy for two
tours got Metals falling out of his ass
are still touring right government tells
him thanks but that's a cck of [__] if I
ever heard one sad day when a
God-fearing white man can't get a job
where's the music
stag in on a
spot could just be background I guess no
I don't think so what do you
want you bastards better not be playing
with each other back
there [__] you Christ look at that
didn't know y'all held that much gold
that Washington's been sh Ling around on
account of the war it's here and he get
sent to Dallas and it comes back it
doesn't make a lick a goddamn
sense here we are feel like a shootout
is going to go
down uh you guys are pretty deep mhm
into this B
so it's going to be a [__] show put
those bags on the table
there I'm up down I'm always down
now is this the first time you're
playing the actual game we did a like
long feature series on it but this is
the first time i' had hands on well
aside time's problem when the flu CL
getting the stream ready [__] that's
some heat right there uhoh used to use C
for it but a year so back we switched
over to
oh that was that was that guy was
[__] we need to move Danny and when
you start talking about being hot give
me a second good thing this furnace was
here gave him a good excuse to say
it
you take care of those guards keep your
ass sure to check out those Gamespot
Studios doing what were they called
specifically Reviving Mafia fantastic
really good stuff why am I oh here we
go deal with the
whoa L of D I'm using money as
cover do do don't know that house we've
been out shut up
[__] told them they needed to be out in
two weeks oh [__] and the man he John
starts laying into me saying the lease
gives them the right to a 30-day notice
that's how he supposed to find a new
place in two
weeks
yeah oh Tommy Gun
yeah all right
so let's go man this place ain't going
to rob
itself
so we get your first question for you uh
can you dip in and out of different
story missions or do you have to follow
the direct story line I mean it's an
open world once you get to a certain
point so I imagine you can just do it
like GTA and kind of pursue them at your
own oh this
combination much you guys enjoy
this sound track this game's
awesome well I'll be downn all right go
for
Godzilla holy [__]
[__] it's beautiful look like he still
has acne right now you see you can get
from does look young as hell here
compared to what we seen we going start
throwing this
down what does his name tag
say oh
Ginsburg damn it you triggered the
[__] alarm [__] I didn't know this
cage was on a different system all right
we're going to hold off the guards until
Danny's done
drilling hey you going to pull this off
love that hair
mhm all right
well that was simple
enough oh I'm out of
ammo you have a gun
they're going to call me a hero for
killing
you got to box them
in going to push
forward he's got a
g that's a hold pick out
ammo oh
nice watch out
though
yeah I get
that all
right I'll keep
that nothing in
that so A lot of people are asking how
long you've been playing this is the
first time yep it's crazy that you did
such a long kind of like doc series and
this is the first time you're finally
getting a touch a game
only played a decent amount Scott I
believe watch it was this during their
trip down to norleans Alexa it was Scott
I just think has done preview yep
coverage [__] come on open
hurry I have much
ammo uh some people are wondering when
the review could possibly go up uh we
haven't said it yet like they didn't
send out early review copies uh I don't
think [__] piece of [__] I mean I
think a lot more games do that now a lot
more companies because of like day one
patches yep yeah which I'm not even sure
the patch probably isn't even live right
now in this version we're playing I
believe Scott is the one who's going to
be reviewing yeah Scott's playing right
now to review
it oh I'm supposed to help him I thought
he said he was
covering no MUSC is going to do it
himself there it is ready expose lock
all
right oh cool
right whoa
missed ignore that one oh no I got it oh
no you got it all right let's do this
nice well this should get things done
very similar weapon selection at
GTA I mean yeah it's machine gun pistol
I think lot of games have
those there we
go
yeah man these guys a [__] around
face way worse than this over at n
little smoke don't be [__] stay close to
the Vault watch for the drill the best
thing I've ever it's the best thing you
could ever
say young guy already done done his semi
had men all over the place one of them
worked at a cleaners and stole the
uniforms Georgie Marcano and Lincoln
clay wore on the day of the robbery
another one was a janitor at the Federal
Reserve and he provided a rough
layout the robbery of the Federal
Reserve was timed perfectly and none of
it would have been possible without the
involvement of Sammy Robinson Lincoln
clay and the rest of the black
mob
you just come from
Vietnam that's right I was a Marine in
the Pacific you take it from
me just because you're home doesn't mean
you're back you
understand people around here they don't
they don't get it
never
will keep your ass out the
trouble somehow I doubt
that oh sick have a better car than that
armored truck
now sorry I'm late got caught up
crossing the bridge don't worry about
it excuse me sir I'm looking for my step
brother linoln CL you seen him he used
to get t off if you were even a minute
late kiss my ass there he is yeah it's a
great shirt I'd wear thata
shirt how was the trip is how this is
the first time in four years and
somebody telling me where to go what to
do or how to do it it was [__]
great the old man immediately drinking
man don't even get me started on
drinking the streets in pull his head at
his ass same as everything brother you
have no [__] idea damn Ellis she's
looking good just like I left her man
even I know not to [__] around with your
carop all right come
on I'm ready to go
home newo is this trash
can all
right simple
enough it's a looks like a while away
let's do it map looks pretty pretty
large s look at that
again got different districts I think
the bayou's down here
yep where am I right now Southdown
French Ward right in the middle so the
French Ward's not obviously this isn't
completely geographically correct they
pulled the Bayou in and put the French
Ro right in the middle they said that
was like in order to keep reminding you
that you kind of in that kind of City
that's just they want you to Criss-Cross
this area a lot ever since we got your
telegram about coming home he's been
climbing the walls what if the plan
crashes what if the trains delay what if
they call him back and he go stand in
front of the kiss your window and sip
his whisky like he was expecting you
come
strolling tighter than don't say nothing
about me telling you that I won't leave
fine once he sees you ever since
mama getting used to
it I don't really follow who follows the
like traic girl do you follow traic
girls in like GTA games no absolutely
not I mean like initially ever yeah the
only time I ever is when there's a
mission where you can't bump anybody but
that's about
it
what all right so apparently if you
drive through red light right is that
what that mean maybe moved up to Empire
Bay year so after you shipped out
started selling weed they call pay
attention red lights in real
life as
concerned
asking
for can't imagine Sammy was too keen on
that never told about the weed that
ain't nothing to nobody but this I got
to talk to him about I ain't said more
than three words and he's yelling about
the fs how we don't need JG up our ass
what the [__] am I thinking selling dop
with kids running around the
neighborhood we ain't selling no dop
Standard Version they got money to
8uy serious [__] a couple
guys pissing off the wrong person got
that throats
cut what that's why I'm talking to
Georgie about it there's no way s's
going to go along with that Georgie says
he keep his old man from fighting out
we'll still clear the hollow and Frisco
just sellling the French wall George's
Uncle L won't say [__] as as as we give
him a taste of the action I don't know
man George is a cool cat but KY come in
on it with us I bet he'd agree to a
three-way split oh weaving it I don't
know I kind of need to lay low a bit
figure some things out yeah all right
get out of my spot hey man be
careful
anyway look who I found P handling out
of the train station pleasure manc back
baby boy I send you to bring linol clo
not the big [__] who hit him well [__]
old man I finally went somewhere they
knew how to
cook welcome home son how are you pretty
sure all these people die better once I
get some of that
sh the R whiske I would like to make a
to
my father used to say that the real
worth of a man came from The Mark he
left on the
word when LOL first told me he was
joining the milit I was against
it too dangerous I say let those people
fight their own War I say but then I
realized lincol needed to go out and
make his Mark and that's precisely what
he
did I'm
so so proud of you
does that mean I know you speak a lot of
French welcome
to the family maybe
good welcome yeah that makes more sense
nice seeing
you
the the intro really appreciate that
father looking young now who wants to
get [__] face the driving feels good for
those asking it's it's like it's tight
enough I guess there is a you can change
it to be more like of a simulator
apparently I can check that out in a
second
Elation
fear
Y imagine being
trapped in a dark room and there's no
way
out and every fear every nightmare you
ever
had is in that room with
you and there's no
escape from any of
it and then one day a door
opens and you're free to
go just like
that the thing
is you made your peace with your Terror
and your fear of
death and now part of
you is afraid to leave it
behind but what choice do you
have every Soldier has to walk through
that
door One Way or
Another Man Whiskey's going to O in the
morning hell man just sleep it off the
room's the same as you left it
I'm going to take the
basement the basement why the [__] you
want to crash down there I'll see you in
the morning we used artillery and [__]
man that wall must have really [__]
you
up objective is go to
bed what yeah it's a great basement oh I
don't know
if no idea if I'm allowed to look at
that oh
dang I I don't see why
now were there any big name that voiced
any of these characters that we know of
uh not that I know of not
positive going to be hung
over oh you can't oh what that's
up just go on PornHub
later not me uh Lincoln
will oh cool thanks thanks for
clarifying
yeah we barely have two nickel strub
together now we paying for all that food
Jesus Christ watch that mouth of yours
we wouldn't be in this mess if you would
have listened to me what
mess there not something you need to
worry about Lincoln I got it under
control under control God damn it you
need Bo I'm not warning you again have
it your way old
man let him
be he needs to cool off you mind telling
me who's got him so riled
up we've been having uh problems with
the
Haitians but like I say I got it under
control well trucks all loaded up I
figure we got enough out
there should I should I come back in
honor of your returning to us safe and
sound I made a donation to Father James
here supplied him with food he can hand
out to some of our Nidia family I was
hoping you'd lend me a hand Lincoln and
give you a chance to see the
neighborhood this thing with the
Haitians how serious is it ah you know
Ellis someone looks at him the wrong way
he's on them like a wet dog like I said
I can now come back
nonsense linol needs to get out enjoy
the day besides be good for the two of
you to spend some time
together go on those people waiting on
their
food all right oh I saw Lang couple
times once he was faced back
he told me he wanted to leave town head
out to
California now he had a friend in the
service who could do a job working at
the mar Island Shipyard and the only
reason he came back was to tell Sammy
and Ellis goodby I like this I like this
documentary kind of feel yeah it's cool
but then he found out about the trouble
Sammy was having with do
Hai so he decided to stay in heaven
the score is awesome those Haitians they
are bad
news no talking lanking out of
it whatever else he might have
become Lincoln was always
loyal so what did you learn about
Lincoln from the documentary series you
guys
man
um I don't know he's like in and out of
foster homes most was life when the Army
he was part of like a special ops group
that like trained Vietnamese soldiers to
like Fight Back start then the union
lets you in ta Sammy and Ellis not yet
wait a few days didn't want to spring it
on them since I just got back they won't
like the head but they'll come around
you need to do what's best for you go
ahead and start serving those folks I'll
be
back all right little little soup
kitchen soup action little soup
action give Sammy my best Lincoln yes
sir get out of here nice pour
next warm meal warm H full
show there
go it's interactive gumbo serving
thanks H gumbo does look Fant what would
you like we have gumbo and gumbo I'll uh
I'll take gumbo please a real blessing
that thank you blessings more soup was
in that bowl and it was in the spoon
Yeah couple days back and they already
got you working I'm happy to do it means
the all of us yeah good this is making
me want gumbo mhm right now here you go
don't get old son it's a [__] [__]
show we'll try not to I'll see what I
can do about
that hey there Lincoln how are you ra
I'm good nice to see you around the
hollow again nice to see those
big well they'll be over at my aunt's
Place me you should stop I'm about to
fight people I'll do that we got trouble
run
ra get
off is next
yeah
who jump
over oh man a lot of head button huh
should I kill him yeah go
ahead guess
so no sou
haian well I just made things way worse
with the
Haitians what are
those fris Papa do dualer was president
of Haiti in
1957 by 1959 he had created a secret
police called tonon makot and people
started to flee uh most of them settled
in the Southern United States now mixed
in with the good hardworking people were
hardened criminals they formed the
backbone of what became the Haitian gang
now Lincoln found out they set up on the
swamp
and we led by a man named Baka yeah
let's go to
Bayou I just killed somebody James done
already got jumped by the Haitians it's
time you level with me tell me what's
really going on they attacked a soup
kitchen
yes I suppose it
is yeah who attacks a soup kitchen when
do I get a SI suit like that seven
months
ago folks in the hollow started getting
robbed money jewelry things of that
nature
didn't take long for us to figure out it
was the
Haitians then those B on started going
after the lottery how much money are we
talking
about how much enough that we in deep
[__] with s
Marano haven't kicked up to him in 3
months Jesus
Christ if I deal with them that gives us
time to settle up with Marano
right let me worry about
Sal he and I go way
back but this thing with the
Haans it's time for it to
end you and Ellis need to handle it how
we going to find them getting ready to
work back in the 20s one of your cohorts
later on Cassandra salt out of the
bou they built themselves a little
shanty town when the Depression hit they
abandoned it that's the only place this
could have come from we're going to need
guns and ammo going to need guns call
this guns got two guns right there
what's any need more
for look at those guns look at those
pythons but do it away from
here no sense tipping anybody off I need
a haircut we could sweep the hollow
track down and kill every last one of
those [__] then we wouldn't have
to worry about it the last thing folks
in this neighborhood need to see is
colored people killing each other
dude this
quiet away from
here once we eliminate whoever's running
the show the rest of them will go down
on their own trust me all right soldier
boy I'll follow your
lead be careful
here those hians are a hard
people do not ever underestimate them
all
right
I don't speak French oh you told me to
speak French all the time man well I do
I just don't want to tell you what he
said it it would spoil
things that's really considera of you
thanks so
much oh okay you sure this is how you
want to play this last thing they're
going to expect is an attack from the
water you head back around to the rad
stay with the car I'll meet you over
there when this is done buet over us
hope you know what you're doing trust me
Ellis here in a bit this will all be
behind us is he staring or I oh he
is go for a nice little swim dude
there's alligators I don't like
alligators there are I saw a compilation
recently well I know there are but I
meant like right
now so I'd get out of there
do all
right how many men we send two teams
one's going to hit the bar the
others what do they call those uh those
boats says we have to burn down half the
H to get to Sammy We're doing it ride
one stop until that old man's dead
you they're all and the other one
Lincoln clay he's the one this time you
won't get away from
us well
[__]
[__] going to the water
nope oh it's just want to shoot
you [__] got something sorry gun's
blazing well probably know I'm
here
whatever come
here somebody was saying the game
reminds them of uh the game shooting
reminds them of Uncharted
that makes sense yeah the reticle I
guess oh here we dude you hungry hey
dude come here come
here
eat eat him you got to give him a
second who
oh he didn't do it yeah I got a pink
achievement whose Xbox is this it's
fuchsia all right I think it's Joey
sweet all right I'm into it this game's
a 10 out of 10
already wait a minute all
right all right so uh where am I
going someone in here let's hope
not I don't even know where I'm
going quiet
should have killed that old man a long
time ago just kill both you so
easily all right think the boss was
worried ask come down on us give me this
glass
bottle I'm going to [__] punch you in
the face so
hard come here come
here a what got to keep it quiet man
punching skulls isn't that loud it's
little it's little
choker this is a shanty
town how does it feel to you so far I
mean we're only it feels good 40 minutes
in but everything feels
tight kind of I'm eager to see like how
the open world will feel once they
actually give me the freedom to kind of
just wander around but I know they're
setting [__] up for the
Revenge hey this is a great question um
they want to know oh let me smoke this
dude first all right sorry what were you
saying can you play this game online uh
uh I don't know what kind of online
functionalities it
has I mean I was definitely I'm
definitely I was online so I'm not sure
if it's like a
yep I don't know that'll be interesting
to see what kind of modes they'll
have I'm going to fill up a pillowcase
full of bars of soap beat the L [__] out
of here I think there might be a tank in
the back of that truck you could blow
but then your cover probably yeah it's
gone I don't I don't I'm not really all
F the quiet I could go around them how
do they not see
you I don't know cuz like I don't know a
lot of games like if it was really
realistic how they see me it wouldn't be
fun it's
unrealistic doing the pacifist approach
uh we are playing it on Xbox um it's
only on Xbox and PS4 is it on PC as
well PC as well
is another good question do you know if
there's going to be a co-op I don't know
I don't think right now they have they
might have plans to do it they don't
have right
now yep n
PC
Nathan says it'll be on
Steam ooh semi-automatic
rifle dude what is that oh [__] a
[__] pay no
attention
sorry
shoot he got shoot
fast stop shooting him
Jesus stop hey o h me Target prce now I
knew you could do this whole stealth
thing no you're just not a stealth kind
of guy I like stealth games a lot hold
on a second wait hold on I have
something oh
[__] put him down put him down put him
down what are you doing what are you
doing I don't know I was going to try to
use a meat
Shield let's try that again oh this is a
long death
scene all right this is Gears you can't
grab so many and hold them in front of
you oh I just but he did and it didn't
work apparently bodies don't stop
bullets in the bayou well not when you
put them over your
shoulder poor execution by Lincoln all
right yeah it was Lincoln not
me
what
D [__]
this hey up
what die [__] Superman hanging out
the the
docks where'd he go
oh
ah
runs oh
[__] this game's going to have a heavy
heavy heavy story emphasis right
yep
yeah go ahead whistle where are they
come
here
what all right whoa sorry we your
people take w out here guns got some
kick can't take more get me out
here so again a lot of questions of how
long we've been
playing
um just got the game this afternoon so
this is Mike's first time playing even
though he did a fantastic dock series
you should check it out oh I thought
going say even though I died no all
right here we go no it's great
documentary series but um he hasn't been
able to play the game so this is you're
seeing his first impressions first time
he's playing I'm not reviewing it but
I'm just playing yep uh Scott will be
reviewing the game um there's no no time
frame for when it'll be done um since we
just got access to the game today it's
also a big game yeah huge
game hold on a second wait hold on a
second come here I got to tell you
something this is definitely not a game
you can rush through the review
so well still rolling
guy got to go quick I bet your
people I don't need
people don't about it shot but so far
everyone wants to know how you're
feeling it's good how is the driving
specifically the driving felt good uh
like I said there's another you can like
activate like a more simulation kind of
driving apparently they were telling me
but not try it yet
go now have you been a big fan of the
mafia series I played two I never played
the first one first was 2002 got ported
to the consoles in 2004 second one was
just 360
PS3 all right let's not try meat Shield
this time how long has it been since two
uh two was
2010 so significant amount of time yeah
all right I'm going to ignore that
guy let me at this
[__] motherucker
I see
you this just feels like a very
interesting time setting in like history
to have something like
this now explain
the the I see you go into those boxes
are you collecting stuff or is that
where you go to heal um I just heal I
believe so you're not collecting
something you could use down the road no
I am
okay I just got one so I
could oh great question uh oh yeah so my
heal's bottom right the green two bars
somebody wants to know what's next for
Gamespot
Studios um we're not talking about it
yet but we already shot our next
one why is who Baka why you
Superman uh yeah it'll be he'll be
within the next
month so be on the lookout s someone
else in this place oh
execution oh hey come here I just want
to
talk [__] you you made a big mistake
going after the hollow
h a lot
bloody to
White the man you're talking about took
me in when I had nowhere else to go you
are no better than you
whoa kind of strong to do
that
[__] that family member I had expected a
little more Gore with that kill
but you get take she's one you become
friend you [__] big you to take it
easy take it easy take it easy he kept
me in there locked in there day and
night beat me use
me I kiss you [__] you and your
entire goddamn family he's dead he's
dead he can't hurt you anymore it's
over
over this is never going to be
P I don't know what she said I don't
know what that means
speak
haian [__]
Haitian uhoh oh [__] all right got a m
MZ how do I use that uh RB maybe ah
they'll probably tell me when I go
outside
yep he knows how what button did you
press tell me there we
go yep there's you know what I am
interested to see
how on the side of his
head this [__] be like
fire he's just nonchalantly with it over
his
head that another gun still here
yeah who's hitting you he's shoting [__]
out of me watch out Rush
[__] I should heal oh I don't have any
heal any
no fastest fastest man alive fire
from got your ass
now he really coming over here get out
of
here your focus needs
a I'm
here where's that
sucker pistols got Range man [__] that
[__] you can shoot through the
wood oh metal there that's a generator
oh [__] oh [__]
oh don't chew me don't do
it oh yeah nice on your
knees not good
cover that bullet sound
pretty
all right let's go we shot
[__] I like this somebody look up what
hot John means and it's it means never
hati sense [__] time go give let me
drive all right
yeah get in get the [__] what is he
doing H you know at that get in at that
point why wouldn't he just drive I
understand for the story
but how do I change the song
yeah down the B you would be pretty
perfect right now hold on I got to look
this
up uh all right controls let's see what
uh check this out uh while driving they
have a in vehicle here we
go
CH did you see it oh right dpad change
radio station hold you out of trouble
don't I you hold I am how to go with Bak
we came to an understanding he stayed
dead not let him let's get back to Samy
can't even tell
you [__] it it's your car bash it up all
you
want people giving it a little Flack for
the uh the way he
TOS [__] with the has been on flick of
the WR huh them out the way things are
calmed down back to the way they should
be been telling him for months we needed
to do something like this but popsy this
kind of give us a good feel for how big
sometimes I think he's lost the taste
for this [__] a man don't rush to
violence
do I know makes me wonder what happens
after you know no I don't know explain
it to me don't matter if it's a bullet
or the hand of God we all go sometime
right I suppose the Ellis we don't need
to talk about I pray that pops outes the
both of us but if he doesn't every
[__] in the hollow is going to
be looking to us or gun and for us just
saying we got to be ready lights on
right now yeah well that's not something
we got to worry about right now so just
cool it with your grand plans all right
yeah all
right how many weapons can you
hold uh it looks like you can unlock
more slots right now just too two at a
time for the beginning cool and is it a
primary and a pistol yeah and then a
moloto or
Dr I'm impressed nice turn wrong lane
but whatever those trees are on
fire
sky and we're back get out of here Jesus
Christ what are you doing man sorry [__]
are you all right that was an
accident you're fine get out of here you
got to get her on the back bro of course
you
yeah the thing lanol didn't understand
all right that might be it for the for
the stream watch this cut understand is
that for a man like Sammy there's always
going to be more
Haitians now if there wasn't someone
going after after Sammy then there was
someone else forcing him into a bad
situation it was never going to
in that's how L can end up working for S
Maro oh man you were right about those
Haitians being down by that old salt
mine they won't be bothering us again it
was a mistake sending you down there I
should handle my own business this is
any different than what I was doing
before I left
you probably don't know
this but every night on the TV right
after the news they show the names of
all the boys Kil over there in
Vietnam i' be sitting in the kitchen
eating my supper watching Nas scroll by
wondering if today is the day I finally
see your name but you never
did nothing happened to me there's only
so much luck down the way
sooner or
later pull up that bucket there's
nothing in
it so what are we going to do about
Marano Pam his gotam money one way other
lottery going to be enough to cover
it the
lottery
no but s called a bit ago wants you to
meet him up the country club follow says
he's got something in the
works Square things up between us the
only black folk out in there they help
they may not like it but they're not
going to say no to S
Maro he says you get to come in you get
to come
in fine always did want to see the
inside of that
place you need to do whatever say last
yeah for all our sakes yes
sir all right play for a little bit
longer see now huh yeah play for a
little bit
longer a lot of comments were saying
they really want to see s
so should I try simulation
driving what's the difference it's going
to be more realistic I'm probably going
to do it
are you shifting
gears
um I don't know probably wait where did
they say that be real
cool game
controls we under control here we go let
try simulation see how this goes do
it oh RPM bar I guess get one free are
you shifting over there check the uh
options I know I know I'm not supposed
to enjoy my coffee on
air oh Gilbert's turning red folks I
don't think I have to shift I think it's
just like more it feels less a little
less doesn't feel be all good old
fashion how many different settings are
there for the driving a little
enthusiastic well I'm sorry realistic
and Arc I am I've talked before about
being honest part crew of knights for
the 10th year run got heck of
a that I was just testing it out yeah I
see with it's a little floatier I guess
more realistic this will be my first
crew since sh [__] yeah oh
yeah what do the driving remind you of
pick another game GTA not this this
reminds me more of like
a or something not that fine tun but
like definitely more like
racing you know tell spend weeks what
nobody used this bridge months prep
nobody
there anything else it was sorry
whoa kidding don't no nothing don't
worry about it no where are we downtown
my father believed that every man had
his role to
play contributed great aole check this
out hit taxi it's not mind I don't want
to even here I don't want to attract
attention right now he driving as he
qual no sir there's always going to be a
king that's a great question and each
King if
you keep the motor in the red in the
RPMs does that hurt the car probably not
oh I see why they want okay here's what
I'm going to do I don't feel like
driving back there I'm going to go up
here on foot
and
then
[__] hold on second yeah this is
working oh [__] here we go you try to
take this
boat wait for it what you bam bam bam
bam oh [__] he's coming slower than I
thought hey come here come over here I
need your I need to talk to you get out
of
here and away we go need a break come to
the cigar that was good I like
that I I don't think that if you keep
the car in the red of the RPM will hurt
it I think it's like a real car that if
you hold down the
Gas
crazy all right
good uhoh um you broke
it you broke it where did that boat go
Michael Mah Hardy ladies and Gent
breaking the game oh say where is that
boat
going what is it doing how much fuel is
in it now you mentioned a is that a bird
is that a plane no it's a goddamn boat
all right you mentioned a day one patch
is that in yet or I would yeah I was try
not to Showcase too much that I didn't
think that would happen hey did you see
that boat in the air no I don't know
what you're talking about got the sweet
Bill bottom yeah I saw it too no you
didn't I saw it you're drunk
where are those people
going going for a nice stroll hey come
here wow it's a long car all
right where you going the ych club I
think you're still pretty
far um about about like 8009 M away or
so yeah we got a station wagon here I
can break into yeah go ahead and take
that take that old uh yep elbow what do
they call them the ones wood inside
Woodies call
Woodies hey
y
club I'm going keep the simulation
controls on cuz heads up
o see what else is
on oh I like this
s yeah all
right don't go around
tonight we're in for Stormy Weather
wow
in case you can't tell I don't take
myself seriously I'm just kidding I
think you have a great voice here we
go oh look at that car old old school
Corvette love it where am I now Frisco
field Frisco San Fran
Frisco oh I don't want the
let's park the car let's listen to
it all right enough of
that hey [__] Ghost Ride the Whip baby
hey the [__] you doing up here shut off
help goes into the oh man I'm uh I'm
here to see Mr Maro the name's Lincoln
clay that a fact I'll be goddamned mind
your manners while you're in there boy
or H to P you here I want to run
everybody over Georgie where you
at
Georgie oh [__] do you see that I do oh
man little old school
Porsche lcking clay Christ man get a
look at you let those [__] go [__]
themselves when they saw you coming been
a long time Georgie oh no [__] has been
a long time I think the last time I saw
you was that night over in the French
Ward right before you shipped out damn
if that wasn't a gas oh I seem to
remember me and Ellis running from the
cops and Danny ending up in the drunk
tank hell man I bail him out Bes just
waed to knock the hell out of them crack
of [__] smoke sure yeah oh man Sammy
said Mr Maro wanted to see me Mr Maro
[__] make him sound like a goddamn
lawyer you just call him
s come on he's in the
back
hey look at
this so this is where all the Italian
people hang out what are you trying to
say about us Italians he squares have a
problem with your drad you take it up
with my old man he'll tell him to kiss
his ass ha his you don't like the tie
thing we having [__] you money turquoise
with a white vest I mind it what's maybe
I hate to cut to the short darling but
I've got a meeting coming up Remy a
pleasure as always sir two more
glasses linoln oh veto from Mafia 2o
this is VTO scaleta he's the one I've
been telling you
about come on let it sit
down so you served in Vietnam huh yes
sir Sou tells me uh you earned a few
pieces of tin over there well I served
with some good men nothing I did would
have happened without them army marines
regular army at first and then I was
recruited to the fifth sfg Special
Forces I told you you was something else
now not that anything's going to go
wrong but just in case godamn don't you
want a man like that on your
side well if you're vouching for him s
that's good enough for
me look I got a couple things to take
care
of thanks for the
drink see you veto that jacket yeah he's
a fly looking dude Christ that Jack New
Orleans [__] carpet bagger commission
sent him down here from Empire Bay about
15 years back he's been a pained my
goddamn ass ever
since well I guess you're wondering what
this is all about yeah Sammy didn't tell
me too
much twice a year the feds take old
money out of circulation and destroy it
over the course of the next few days
that money's going to be delivered here
to the reserve in town and you're going
to hit one of those
shipments no sir we are going to use
that occasion to gain access to their
vault and then steal everything that
ain't nailed down should be 6 s million
in there
easy that's that's pretty [__] ballsy
it's a chance of a goddamn lifetime is
what it is now beo FR lot the money for
the job any got us the combination to
Dev VA hey you had a chance to see Danny
no not yet oh Well you will we brought
him and his old man in on this we're
going back we going to need your help so
go see them they still in that same
place there's something else we got to
talk
about now safe to assume you know about
the problem Samy's been having I took
care of the Asians once things settle
down money start coming in again you see
that right there that's what I'm talking
about you didn't sit around with your
thumb jammed in your ass you saw a
problem you went out and took care God
damn I take that over money any day of
the week we pay our own way debts and
all always have hell son I know that I
wouldn't expect otherwise but you know
even after we all evened up you're still
going to be slopping around in the ass
end of this city not much of a future in
that but maybe there's a different way
forward you understand for all of us
what you have in
mind I want you to know I mean no
disrespect when I say this sami's a hell
of a man but he's not getting any
younger oh I see I'm thinking it's time
to make a change St well I don't think
that Ellis is ready for that kind I'm
not talking about Ellis I'm talking
about you I want you to run the
holler I can't do
that well look at here if you're worried
about Sammy don't you understand now
he's always been on the level with me
and this job we're talking about there's
more than enough for him to retire on he
took me in when I had nowhere else to go
treated me like a
son I'm sorry Mr Maro I can't do that to
him they don't care they're going to do
it
anyway well [__]
son I'd be lying if I didn't say I
wasn't just a little
disappointed but I get it you're
loyal which is something to the scar
these
days do you still want me to help with
this thing we've been talking
about you goddamn right I do and when
it's all done you all be M square with
me you have my
word what do you really want to hear
that we'd kidnap and torture anyone
suspected of working with the
VC I'm trying to ascertain the level of
training that Lincoln clayed during his
time in Vietnam someone like that you
don't need to train you point them in
the right direction you get the [__] out
out of their
way hell
yeah really like this documentary style
yeah digging it big time you meet up
with that CIA D at some point all right
back to the beginning oh we're
back goddamn thing oh [__] let's see if
we can get
back stay cool we'll get through
this
[__] I got eyes on the suspect
[__] nice how can what have like spider
senses now from Vietnam whoa Lincoln
you're bleeding quite a lot looks like
he's wearing a red t-shirt Jesus Christ
except for it hasn't touched that right
sleeve that right sleeve is nice and
white excuse
me wow do the machine gun coming at you
like that I like his walking animations
you a right
sleeve punch somebody in the face yeah
we good where's what just come through a
hole he pushing everything off to the
side so we have room to catch the money
all right once you square the way up
here we start driving it down make it
quick huh
[__] killed the lights just
worry about the doesn't matter I have
spider
SS get me out of
here give
me look at the flame at the end of the
gun that's fantastic a
awesome has been tra yeah I do
they're trying to flush us out stay
focused on what you're
doing yep yep yep yep yep
yep what's he think he's
doing ain't those the gods claiming to
be from Baton
Rouge
godamn
Massacre [__]
how
what what are you guys doing what are we
doing here why am I I'm going to keep
killing
you stop doing that bothering
me [__] criminal and today you die
who's
talking your ass oh there's one more I
shot a gun of course you found
me God damn it those gods are cut us
down tell Danny he needs to get us out
of here and these bastards got us need
to figure something out I got some TNT I
put on outside the hole and detonate it
all right what the [__] is that going to
accomplish with any luck it'll blow a
hole big enough for y'all to drop down
with any luck daddy do you even know
what the [__] you're doing come on this
dynamite how complicated could it be
it's lit get the [__] away from oh sweet
all right um let me use my
PE what whoa all right that works Sweet
let's load her
up wonder if your boy that was
underneath is okay um hopefully Sammy
where's he
at oh yeah boat
Escape off I'm trying D his leg is
pinned I need your help of course you
need no one really knows why Sal marono
turned on to Miss Burke uh but he took
Point Verdun from him and gave it to an
enforcer named Roman the butcher Barbary
who promptly busted up one of burk's
legs friend his last name is bar Danny
Burke was part of the heist crew yeah he
was a Gearhead had never done anything
like this before but thomasb insist he
get away dude he figured if the heist
was a success sa would forgive him and
return point for
done
all you penetrator all
right hey all right now I heard there
ain't nothing sweeter than Vietnamese
[__] you tell me it's
true C NOA clay [__] B it's so [__]
good to see you you too Danny that's
Nikki go she wanted to be here but I
remember I old a God damn you piece of
[__] yeah unfortunately come on let's
grab a beer wait for the old man to chw
out and then we can get
jackets yeah you do yeah I already got
it all set up and organized all the
girls going to be there and everything
except we just got to go in my car cuz
we can't roll up in that beat up piece
of [__] outside know you didn't just
call my All American machine a beater
I'm just saying there better rides out
there hey [__] there are this car's
a beast dro the custom 358 in before
shipped out that ain't the only thing
you dropped in there maybe you should
tell them about how you'd borrow it from
Ellis and take the ladies for a ride
hell man leave me out of this you
[__] my car ain't no big deal I was
always wrapped up tight besides I
already got one [__] Bast in my life
I don't need another one all right you
know what you going to clean it not just
the back seat every square inch I don't
need to be riding around sitting in your
[__] hey and you funny man you going to
[__] help like hell I am [__] I
didn't get any yeah well it's just no
Jesus Christ you [__] Joker got about
as much chance of pulling this off as I
do at winning a godam de cathlin all
right d we hear
you Danny and Ellis you're going to use
the drills to cut a hole up through the
bottom of the Vault you and Georgie
you'll be inside you're to drop the
money down then get the hell out of
there that godamn drill and easy to move
though so we need a boat to get it
through the canals and into position Els
and I worry about the boat to George's
old man flipped the guard at the reserve
giving you his
truck between that and the uniforms and
no one going to give us a second
look come on let's get moving still got
to swing by skelet and finish up some
prep work hey and you two [__] don't
think this gets you off the hook when it
comes to my car y' best get ready to
clean it I ain't cleaning [__] hey you
cleaning
it my father was a lot of things few of
them good
but he started out smuggling moonshine
so he knew about the canals underneath
the city and that one of them went right
under new doesn't have canals and
tunnels under the city but they was his
idea to use a boat to move the drill
into position too much water there to
really build something like that a real
son of a [__] my
father than anyone else I blame him for
what
happened you want to stick your own neck
out fine but leave your son out of it
it's his fault Danny
died spoiler gez
lady
toy is everyone in we need to go we here
go
the I'm going to turn
these off what these uh driving things
oh okay
okay mother the [__] cutting off our
skap we'll find another way out of here
this tunnel has to go
somewhere
yeah
with coming and it's the [__] cops
[__] they opening
fire
the
easy you sister [__]
C take that you [__] pigs yeah shoot
them keep going don't oh [__] sorry
watch what you doing shoot that this
thing is screwed up [__] you you goddamn
[__] sucking oh man guys we might be
dead
guys
fire let's just get there before this
blows
up punch it Lincoln are you out of your
[__] mind [__] [__] [__]
oh oh dude I wish I want have saw to
kick in right
now everybody all right that was the
craziest [__] thing I've ever saw I'm
glad we're breathing and all but what
the hell we going to do now well our
only option is to head
up are you kidding me there'll be cops
all over the place well but any luck
they'll be too busy dealing with M Gro
notice us let's go well damn it this
ain't a
gas hey you sure you need to grab that
much of my ass oh shut up and keep
climbing
man okay give me come we got
all right once we get out there I hit a
pay phone call in a ride can you walk
yeah somebody give me a hand I can get
around uh it's probably just going to be
easier to carry a sorry ass hold up come
here hey hey don't P me the [__] down if
anybody asks we say he's drunk y'all
pick up that money let's go yeah oh God
the bloody leg was from
drinking
he fell
down we're playing on Xbox for those of
you
asking oh
my youing for this time keep it down oh
actually you get a look at the titties I
mean nightm Dam damn it shut your mouth
before you get us
arrested stop godam it stop [__]
you do I hear some more rolling
sounds I don't
know hey man get off the phone right
[__] now hey my time is just as
precious as
yours sacks and sandal that's bold dude
sh y'all keep an eye
out keep an eye out make sure you don't
do anything suspicious like have a body
over your shoulder where some deep [__]
and need your help where are you just
off the parade route Danny's hurt I
can't get a car to you because the roads
are close off listen there's a grocery
store on the back side of the
cemetery can you get over there
yeah there'll be a car waiting at
lenar and Lincoln be careful here you
and ell sport we
will all right not cool go through the
parade looks like Sam's having a car
delivered it'll be at the loaded AR at
the grocery store God bless the old man
let's
go
nice looks like the parade has stopped
people party
this what it uh what it really looks
like no New Orleans or the parade yeah
new Orin I guess so this like Bourbon
Street equivalent looks
like me the's
over an unold number of federal off off
were Ked today
when
what I don't know when shot told you we
need to keep
moving n same song just different you
for the last you need to tell me what
you did with
the
Iber found Abed the French W all units
respond suspects are a negro male
approximately 6'4 a male approximately
5'1 and two unknown accompli they are
armed and extremely dangerous yeah we
are [__] they found the boat stay cool
looks like the dude
caring yep it was pretend to be
drunk there's something wrong with that
boy yeah Wast lucky I don't leave your
drunk ass in a ditch God don't [__]
wasted uh there you
go watch where you're going pay no
attention all right here we
go everybody
justed what the [__] are we going to do
[__] pigs everywhere Ellis chill out
everything's going to be fine all right
you guys take Danny and the money get to
the car I'll deal with the cops I'll War
them off you hey no [__] way man it's
all right he ain't going alone
we all got a friend in Jesus amen all
right let's
go they're on Johnny kigan while I
fight hey over
here
whoa supicious
all
right it's pretty
uh
invting located onene
engaging need a
car there he is let's
go
some
everyone run go through the
cemetery not sure a car is going to help
you in this
situation watch there's T of the ceter
you're about to walk
nice all unit negative visual on suspect
begin search in immediate
vicinity
don't you say
[__] oh that dude's walking toward me
that dude's walking toward me hurry up
Lincoln get off the
wall all right nice
nice
Avail individual on fo offic
investigating
have to escape them in a
second let's just keep
looking where's Georgie we got separated
before we lost sight of him he said he
meet us back at the house get
in where we going off
inva oh let
go lose
him on officers engaging respond
sorry knew you were going for it of
course
I cosmetic damage in the car looks
pretty light
though having some
pring visual contact with suspect lost
well we manage to get out of this I'm
sleeping on the bed at titties I don't
care what [__]
cost they
gone yeah yeah man they done I knew we
can pull it up I knew it we're rich
[__] something
happened I fought thew and the can kiss
my
ass I thought the law and the law
lost all
right all
right we got cut scene
here well how much is it a little over
$2
million for
split holy mother God was everything
settled up I'm calling a man I know
having him bring over three hookers boy
ain't no hooker ever stepping foot in
this house you sure cuz two of them off
for
you I'm going to be [__] in my new
Drifter I'd appreciate that you know my
entire life there's always been someone
standing over me telling me where I
could go what I could do who I could be
seen with [__] is this the scene where
the but you I did
tonight
this changes
everything this isn't just
money it's
Freedom real
Freedom ain't no one standing over me
again over any of
us
W well well well
man and look at what I dug up get mind
pouring one more those holy [__] it
would be my pleasure geud you told me
ship went sideways doing the robbery
Lincoln had to save your ass you should
be damn proud of that boy I am s more
than you'll ever know oh Jesus Christ
that is some down home Hooch right right
there is it all right listen I got a guy
outside yall mind if he comes in and
packs up my cut not at all a few people
with guns you going to handle this down
on Mo you give me some of that to get
some corn make you a man they all the
same hey take the one on the here it's
your cut plus what I owe you even put in
a little extra for your trouble couldn't
have pulled it off without you Sammy
you're all done right by me
tonight why you get us something off the
top we need to
celebrate you ain't got to tell mece
fill me up something L possibly the
baddest [__] I have laid my eyes
on you shouldn't have said no
whoo where the [__] you think you're
going
stupid [__] [__] come on grab that
back let's
go when I got the
samis the whole place was
burning I still don't know what brought
me there that
night
look buy
Providence or something else
is it's probably a good places I need to
end wow so thus Begins the Revenge
tale right um when I was pulling Lincoln
out of the fire woke up long enough to
tell me to call John
Donovan so that's what I
did most days I wish I'd never made that
call Mr
Donovan do you know this
individual sure Sal Marano mhm and how
about this man that s's worthless piece
of [__] Brother Lou
look enough of the dog and pony
[__] what's your real
question did you help Lincoln clay
murder Sal Marano and all prominent
members of his crime
family you're goddamn right I did yeah
all
right
going yeah if you're watching this
you're it might be spoiled I mean kind
of
yeah yeah we're about an hour and a half
into the game so all right I'm going to
skip this all right cool we'll end it
there all right
friends well cool watching yeah Mafia 3
is on PS4 Xbox One PC tomorrow and like
some parts of the world it's out like
later today I think you could pre-load
it right now um yeah so uh if you get
the chance we got a lot of coverage on
it review I know Scott's starting it
today uh we're not sure when it'll be
done it's a big game so he's going to be
working this had a feel for that first
hour and a half good the driving felt
good you that simulation driving is a
little more realistic but uh I'm digging
The Vibes like the documentary
storytelling the music's awesome I like
the character so far they're all pretty
uh well written so far um obviously a
little buggy but that might be fixed by
the day one patch um tomorrow and uh
yeah we'll have our review up sometime
obviously keep an eye out for it you
know no time like immediately it's a big
game uh and then and yeah watch Reviving
Mafia we've got a documentary series
kind of like chronicling uh hanger 13
formation the developer why they chose
to like set the game here at this time
in this place and uh yeah cool uh
everybody thanks for watching Nick
thanks for hosting yep yep thanks for
having us guys hope you guys enjoyed it
and um yeah we'll see you next time go
and uh check out those doc series Mike
did a fantastic job all right see you
guys see
you